you
good morning Millennials hoot morning
Millennials welcome to the morning I did
that I my show in Detroit I was like my
remember when this was like the coolest
[ __ ] wait it was like this huh
you gonna hit your head no you gotta go
that loner head is for finesse yeah okay
whatever well good morning you guys
welcome to the morning shows the
Millennium morning show the greatest
thing since sliced [ __ ] bread since
toast oh that's good thanks
what's new um so much is new I feel like
so much does happen we have so much to
talk about there's so much television to
recap yes I have a list of all that
there's a good amount of news to recap
um and then just yesterday was just so
busy with busy work also there was I
really like to be in tune with like what
people say about our show like the
listeners I don't give a [ __ ] what like
the haters say but some of the listeners
like I'm the YouTube comments turns
really mean yesterday they were saying
stop with all the personal chat in the
beginning I thought that was one comment
I know but like does that speak for the
majority and it's also do you guys
really come here to like get your hard
news like I'm sorry totally you know
that we just do the news is like a
structure to talk about ourselves right
so you're in the wrong show I just like
let us know I just like I never want to
be like out of touch do you know what I
mean - it's like with the singing am I
out of touch and I'm getting such mixed
reviews about the singing but one
comment does not attend me no no
opposite because if there is only one
comment about that it's only the haters
who's everyone who's happy with the show
is not little comment it's right so
think you know how many viewers
listeners we have that many people
disagree with that person okay you feel
letter I do something we have to talk
about it just right out of the gate is
the basis challenge oh my god that took
the world truly advice I was so and like
I'm never busy I was so busy yesterday
and I was so mad cuz my phone was dying
and all I wanted to do was be on my
phone reading there was over 800
comments okay it all started obviously
we're all good things start in the
morning toast Facebook group and if
you're not in it I'm really sorry but
like we'll get you there at some point
this year it's only done right so one
girl was like I thought it would be
really funny it's like text to one of
the Jeff Bezos released leaked
text messages to my boyfriend I'm like
see how he'd respond and her boyfriend
was like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about we don't even get the newspaper
and it spiraled into every girl doing it
and it turned into
Challenge I did it to Ben he literally
was like what the hell are you talking
about he little responded lol what I did
it stackin before I used to Zack I
texted you I was like I'm actually
scared to do it because he's gonna be
like oh that's so sweet like I would
love to and then I would have to be an
[ __ ] and video I'm [ __ ] with you
anyways I did it to him and he called me
immediately cuz he was so shut course
and then when he came home last night I
haven't told you this he like brought it
up again and I was like yeah like what
were you thinking he was like honestly I
was so excited I was like this is what
I've been waiting for oh my god stop
like there was it went one of two ways
like some of the funniest responses with
the boys being like it's just so shook
and then other times the boys being like
oh man I'm so happy that you said that
and like honestly like we don't deserve
boys as pure as that no and now all
these girls either they had to be an
[ __ ] and tell him that they're just
[ __ ] with him or they're behind right
now is paper right now there are girls
all around the world drinking coffee in
bed and reading the newspaper because of
Jeff Bezos and I mean good for Jeff
Bezos because he does so in the
Washington Post oh my god all comes full
circle article integration totally
synergy imagine all of this was her the
Bezos challenge the newspaper
subscriptions would go up honestly it
was so funny thank you to all the
toasters who shared their screams needed
it was just the greatest afternoon I was
in this car oh my god also I don't
weirdest experience in an uber in uber
as I'm discovering the Bezos challenge
I'm like on my phone and then obviously
I started hysterically laughing and he
goes he's like did you just see a joke
on your phone I'm like what do you mean
he's like you just lit up for the first
time since you were in my car I'm like
excuse me why should you be lit in the
car and were you staring at my face the
whole time look at the road like we look
[ __ ] and I was just like okay and then
and then I called you and I guess he was
just like like watching me sit was so
much and he goes are you from Long
Island I'm like technically yeah he's
like I could tell you got that Long
Island look and I'm like well about me I
literally was like I'm insulted and he
was like are you really I'm like it like
he wants to [ __ ] with me I'll [ __ ] way
back totally you're not a flesh I said
I'm absurd and I'm upset and I'm hurt
I'm so and I got out of car he's like I
really hope you're not upset I'm like
now I'm just like with you [ __ ] you it
was just a very weird stalkery
altercation like if I woke up and he was
standing over me I would not be in the
least bit surprised maybe he works for
Jeff besos and he
spying on you do your armpits ever get
itchy sometimes and then you feel like
an actual monkey itching your arm like
my orbits so itchy because I tried new
Jetta and I guess it's just not working
for me and I want to H my armpit but I
feel like Chile like I could like I feel
like a gorilla baby monkey that's all
you have to do speaking of and we got a
bunch of questions about this in the
past week we are working on new merch it
is some of our most I think high-quality
high-fashion merch it's really cool
stuff yeah and it's all of the board
it's obviously your usual like [ __ ] that
we need but it's also we're getting a
little bit more creative maybe like a
notebook you know yeah getting a little
bit more into it like the fashion realm
and also inside jokes that do translate
to the rest of the world so yes you
don't have to be an insider to know
what's going on we're just trying it out
obviously we're going to drop it the way
that we always do 24 hours unlimited
stock get what you wanted or bribe in
two to three weeks well let you know the
drop date soon speaking of merch last
night they went to SoulCycle with the
snitch I took her to music on Monday I
took another chance on a cinch and what
do mean you took a chance that's because
I've every time I bring her to musical
my name would you know I I preach her
out every week she like it's always like
a weird class like I said only on
Mondays yes okay like they play like a
little too much Chicago it's just like
oh like the few times sheets come it's
been like the least Feeny classes oh you
think it's her fault no it's just like
bad luck it and every time she's just
like I'm never coming back
anyways I took her last night and not
only was it so great in Seanie but when
we were getting ready there was like
what we were walking to the locker and
there was a phone on the bench with the
morning to his pops a comment and
embargoes know like it was there was a
toaster there whatever and then like a
few minutes later I was on the other
side of the room like getting my shoes
on and there was a phone that with
Margo's case in the morning to his pops
a kid on it's like mark you left your
phone here she was like no I have mine
and there's another toaster in the wild
god maybe I should start hand it so like
no so there are so many toasters that go
to this musical Monday class and it's
just it makes it even toastier and
senior and she had a good concert now
she's gonna come back we she was really
helpful for me because I was just going
to say before you move into something
else I want to address a musical Monday
thing I was like I could feel the
conversation moving in a new direction
and I didn't want to get you know left
behind I was going to say if there was
another musical Monday this week I would
go with you because I'm gonna be ending
this weekend with famous people and
that's just like really hard for me and
I'm really trying not to eat this week
but it's like I feel like I lost all
this weight and I don't even remember it
being hard I'm having the hardest time
now like I guess what happened I can't
stop eating it I didn't eat a single
thing yesterday I was so good like just
like some grilled chicken and Wheat
Thins I get home at like 8 o'clock you
know it's been we need so much Chinese
food like but like is it that bad
because I got any eat anything else a
whole day so much okay
I had honestly where I get lost on the
Chinese food is the rice you know that
like the mini containers like old-school
Chinese white containers that do you
know that they fold into plates that's
what their point is yeah I never
realized that I've never done it and
they don't even serve those anymore and
I remember my dream growing up was to be
live in my own apartment and eat out of
the containers because obviously as kids
that's what session the city charter
right and now they'd and now it comes in
Tupperware I know and then you still
wash well I ate a whole thing of rice
like not I'm not a huge white one a
little white okay and and like some
chicken not terrible the rice isn't
great I know but I don't know if I told
you this but I really came to the
conclusion that rice is my favorite food
I you didn't have to tell me I know that
every time that we have a meal breakfast
lunch or dinner is there rice with this
I mean what's so funny there's never
rice like rest week in July they serve
rice rice is my least favorite food what
it's it's like fruit in the sense that
it's such a waste of a fattening food
like it's not even tasty well I need
like recommendations because like rice
is really easy to make at your house
like not boiling water like maro Lewin
Jackie's friend gave me the best tip
about Uncle Ben's rice pilaf which is
what in the microwave I could so easy it
just make it for you but like it's kind
of hard to make rice and it sticks to
the bottom of the pan so I'm only
interested in microwavable rice okay I
just [ __ ] love rice I'm happy for you
but back I'm so excited about yours Oh
musical my fish I wish you'd come
yesterday because I know those guinea
three greatest showmen songs were played
okay which ones um this is me Missy
Elliott remix which I requested you're
welcome um rewrite the stars which was
appreciated in a workout format and
tightrope Sara Bareilles version which I
never appreciated until it was played
during so Wow okay actually I'm also um
defying gravity was the last song at and
we were dead four [ __ ] scenes Oh
forever from the urban Hansen and
waiting through a window Reena
oh [ __ ] it was good stuff well so mama
Mia which if you're in which I hate
Mamma Mia but mama me oh yeah totally is
good well I really used to be against Oh
psycho because like the whole seed thing
and I'm still against Oh psycho but when
we did our toast cycle for charity which
we donated twenty five hundred dollars
to get to five III didn't hate it and it
felt really good afterwards it's like
that's it's the endorphins that like
make you want to do it so and now that
I'm gonna be animating to it and I
really just like I can't stop eating so
maybe I can negate that by doing one so
like a like a month maybe well if
there's like a bomb like class location
and music you let me know I'm gonna look
at the schedule and you have to because
my favorite instructor who does musical
- also teaches a Wednesday class we
could go to some but it's not like you
don't know what he's gonna play
sometimes I don't even know one song
about this but I enjoy this they're just
good I know this is a lot to ask but if
there's like a soul cycle teacher out
there who's interested in just like
letting me choose a class to come to and
like choose all the songs I will go
because it's the one thing I can't [ __ ]
with with SoulCycle is that your entire
workout is based on someone else's
musical style and like music tastes
right now but that's why you have to
find the instructor like um so I love
Nick is the one who to use musical
Mondays I mean you know Margaret I used
to go to page in how she felt her to
rumble but she was like all Taylor Swift
all Lady Gaga all the time yeah like if
you teach in New York and your toaster
just like hit me up at the DMS let me
know what class to come to and set me
the setlist in advanced record like at
least study it you know yeah I just it's
for a class that's so predicated on
music putting some of that faith in
someone else is really hard for me I
understand I understand I'm gonna when I
got new bathing suit you know I've had
like the same five bathing suits for
like ten years there's something
revolutionary that happens to a woman
when you realize like what kind of
bathing suit looks good on you you know
what I got two of the same style you're
right one-piece one arm stylin violin so
long I never owned any bathing suits
that we just wear like an American
Apparel
banjo and like under and shorts like it
was like I don't wear bait I'm not a
beading so you know but I know you found
yours I know what it is what it's like
it's not high-waisted but it's like
high-waisted and it's like a sports bra
type it's like the green one that you
have yeah well I had one way to I have
all of those ones yeah it's like right
about at the belly button yeah you know
um and then I need all the support on
top I can because I think the least
flattering part of the female body is
like the power part of your stomach
below your belly button
yeah that's where
perhaps where it's hardest for me to
lose weight but it's also like one name
might knock on wood hopefully my babies
are gonna be true situated in there and
they're gonna have so much room and
they're gonna and they're not gonna have
been damaged by the Sun oh yeah I know
and they're just gonna it's roomy
you know yeah so anyways I'm gonna look
into a SoulCycle class for you because
yes I'm I'm interested in this journey
of yours yeah I mean I am going to
workout today again with live method I'm
going to do that so sore I know but it's
a part of my journey to become a smaller
woman well I'm going to Mexico two times
in one month and they're both like whis
people which I hate going on vacation
with people but like scary just trip to
Mexico this weekend is so much fun and I
just I have to be there I can't not be
there and it's my best friend's wedding
so it's like of course I want to be
there for her but also like everyone in
the world it's gonna be there it's like
a 600 person wedding of everyone I've
ever known in my life
and everyone's gonna beach together I'm
just gonna be like no you know yeah I
need to like a look the best I possibly
can in a two-week span you could do it
and you know how else you could do it
with noon what's up noon you'll have a
personalized training on your own
support team for less than the price of
a single appointment with a nutritionist
or a personal trainer so numa's this app
where you can put in all your weight
goals oh my god everything thank you so
it's like apps that like condense my
[ __ ] for me no no it's like you it
tracks you and they give you like
support and encouragement and like tips
and tricks because you tell them what
you want to do you another per I just
love where I can put in my information
and someone tells me how to be better
okay but have you ever like done one of
those apps and like lied about you're
right like I haven't then it's like
there's no way if anything I always go
like a little above so that I can look
sort of everyday totally so they do food
tracking and everything and they just
take the stress and the worry out of it
like and the unknown like if you just
track all these things like a plus B
equals C it's very mathematical you know
it's so true it'll help you meet all of
the goals that you want to achieve
Noom is designed for results meet your
resolutions by signing up for your free
trial for your trial today at noon
n-o-o-o m.com slash toasts what do you
have to lose visit noon calm / toast to
start your trial today
again that's Noom calm / toast start
losing weight for good i've been really
doing this because this is like with my
resolutions and my weight loss journeys
the weather fitness and now that i'm
doing all this work it's like yeah I
want to see it all the time I won't yes
no one grabs at my coat rack progression
I would like all my program progress
printed in a graph and put in the
McKenzie file for me right like what's
the point of progress if someone's not
gonna print it out for you what's the
point in progress if there's not proof
like you know what I mean that's like
where everyone's doing this 2009 2019
challenge and honestly I'm sit the age
where 2009 I didn't have any digital
photos like sane like I don't know I
didn't have one picture of me I was in
the ninth grade
like I might have like one very very old
facebook album that one of my friends
put on my clock because it was so mater
say do you like when other people share
theirs like I wonder if never to share
mine wouldn't perform well well I just
watched more in Bushnell's Instagram
story and it was wildly interesting cuz
she just did all these years before the
bachelor like when her family moved to
LA when she was a flight attendant and
like it's just interesting to see how
people's face change and she was
literally like the shape of my face
changed she said I used to have a round
face and now I have like a more oval
pointy face yeah
and she's like she said that and no I
was looking at old pictures even I'm
like from college and stuff and like my
face really has changed and yes when I
got eyebrows which helped but it really
was so much like just like rounder and
juicier right and now honestly I mean
it's all the lymphatic drainage maybe
but I just feel like my face just like
it's better well I know why my face is
better I got a [ __ ] surgery right
someone who hasn't gotten surgery like
right like no it wouldn't be a puzzling
to me you know right that's true but I
don't have pictures from 2009 good for
you I feel like I really started
Facebook like photos to have 2012 when I
was in college
yeah and that's an Instagram started on
the art scene yeah I was very artsy in
college I know well actually so who ever
hated the personal stuff is gonna hate
this episode Margo just sent me the
video of Maggie Rogers in the Pharrell
class offended me too she's copy and
paste totally she the first time I saw
this I didn't really care but then I
realized it's Maggie
Rogers totally and by the way like we're
in a chat cuz me like a toast ciao I
don't know why she just didn't put it in
there whatever it was so interesting
that when she said it to me I was like I
like I'm like I like my new Rogers and I
know that I introduced you guys to her
so I feel good about this but shouldn't
this be for Claudia you guys like love
her yeah well you know it's just so
funny because like she in the video like
she's very like she says she's the rural
juror she grew up in like a rural town
she like played banjo her whole life and
came to NYU to make banjo music and folk
music
and then she had this experience where
she studied abroad in France and she
really learned disco and like tech and
like dance music which she was taught to
believe was so artificial but she when
she was in France she understood it she
definitely was on drugs like it just
sounded just like that but then so they
play the song and Pharrell says you know
I hear your story in the music like you
you wanting banjo but you liking dance
and feeling the dance and honestly I
heard it too it was really like it so
it's an interesting video that is
interest as someone who thinks like all
that's [ __ ] I totally heard Maggie
Rogers story in that song very cool just
a thought an interesting factoid that's
well interesting that's the thing about
interesting factoid is it here's the
thing they're interesting okay are you
ready for the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast of
course I am and then after that we're
gonna recap all the things Bachelorette
I mean bachelor about shoppings I've and
then a proper all's fire festival fire
fraud yeah I didn't watch the Vanderpump
rules um hold off I think holds up CG
watch what happens live no I can't not
talk about it though but no I was
watching fireworks I think you were
watching it and we're gonna talk about
it I just told you guys to watch the
last seven minutes because I can't what
else told me to watch the last seven
minutes because it finally exposes the
corrupt evil nature of one [ __ ] Jerry
and I didn't watch the whole thing but
I'm going to even if you had told me
even I realize you said that I can't
just watch the last time and it says
something that I want to watch the whole
thing up I need the whole story but I
was like already ten o'clock and I was
super tired I know and then I stayed up
till like 12:30 watching oh I'm so sorry
and one other another terrible thing
[ __ ] Jerry has done totally alright
let's jump okay let's jump right into
the first story which is a little
shocking because Rob Kardashian is back
on the scene with a new woman
Alexis sky amid her feud with blac Chyna
even though she's Chyna I figured this
was something that we should be
discussing nice let me temporary he was
making photos on Chyna her she was
taking photos in kris Jenner's kitchen
oh yes so Rob Kardashian might have a
new lady in his life the reclusive
former Keeping Up with the Kardashians
star shares videos on snapchat of Alexis
sky cooking a feast at what appears to
be kris Jenner's mansion where Rob now
lives after running into various
financial snafus snafus what a great
word he didn't know that Rob was living
at Christmas not until this The Love &
Hip Hop alum served macaroni and cheese
baked chicken wings
more yum big I'm sorry big chicken drama
wings and more yeah both sound good
so do baked chicken wings totally what's
up guy who shares a one year old
daughter with Fetty WAP also share was
selfie lounging and generous kitchen
sipping on a drink
Rob's dinner guests come comes only a
few days after he posted about his crush
on her Monday my WCW I've been wanting
you for so long Rob wrote over a photo
of her of course fans already suspicious
of the pairing us 24 year old sky and
Rob's ex-fiance Bach China are in an
intense view that resulted in violence
at a party over the weekend I didn't
even know this robbing China who shared
daughter dream have also been tied up in
legal war over child support
honestly it's amazing what you miss out
on when you China someone who's so toxic
you know I don't know any of this I
don't know any of this and and now I'm
glad that it's just popping up back when
I need to know back once someone's in
Chris's kitchen I need to know this is
this is now a need-to-know situation and
I really feel as if Rob Kardashian needs
to stop dating people out of spite and
in this like beef crew like get a new
crew this is obviously toxic you ended
up with a spike baby who thank God it's
growing up to be cute because like at
first we didn't know but he is making
such bad life decisions but on watch
rapid live last name Andy asks like
how's Rob and they said he's really good
any might be on the new season I hope so
she they just said and it was kind of
like really relatable he was like he's
just Moody and like sometimes he's like
I didn't sign up for this show I'm not
doing it and sometimes he's like alright
I'll sit down and I'll do it okay that's
relatable but it seems to be more than
that it's not like I feel like that's
where Kylie's at sometimes she's in it
and sometimes she's no but she doesn't
take a paycheck from it takes six years
off but I think I the mood that's a life
so remember like a couple years ago it
was news that they made a hundred
million dollar deal with E how do you
think they split that up even late is
what I read evenly between all of them
even Kylie yes well I guess like she
makes the family more interesting
they're there for the show I think Scott
gets paid just as much as Kourtney just
as much as camp really yeah I think and
I I think Rob even gets paid from that
um because I don't think that Chris
would leave him out so do you think
Chris gets paid as a cast mate and it
also gets 10% of everyone else's is she
making the most on the show um I think
she gets 10% of the whole deal so she
got ten million from that which is
probably how they divide it up they
divide it up to new there's a ton of
them anyway yeah I don't know when you
think about it it's like not that much
just because there's so many like
you definitely doesn't get paid no no
but like Kim Kourtney Khloe Kylie
kendall Chris Scott Cory and then I
think Cory Jonathan Malika probably get
ancillary yeah like the paychecks are
but like main characters would be the
seven of them okay - taxes yes like ten
million dollars each it's so crazy
because they're actually that was for
how many years of work ten that's a lot
of work I'd like for ten million dollars
like you could just do ten Instagram
posts but I do remember like when their
show got re when they got these new ten
seasons like they were having a lull in
in they haven't always had steady
ratings and the Kris Humphries thing
really did help but for a while like
they didn't know like if they were gonna
so it was a wise decision for them to
buy chances when we were watching that
old episode of Kim and Shengo which by
the way I still ship was the greatest
love story of our generation she was
really acting like the show was so
different he was like really like not
scripted but like these fake situations
and Kim's like not being herself like
now they so sorry about my mom now they
put a camera down in the living room
they're like do whatever the [ __ ] you
want right it's almost like but that's
also the trend of reality TV if you
watch reality TV from a couple years ago
we didn't realize we're so like we're so
smart now like we see something we're
like that's totally scripted but back
then it was like reality TV was so new
so they could be scripted we're like no
that's real you know but now we're
smarter so like they have to get smarter
yeah and they have yeah except for Rob
who's dating Alexis guy except like I
want him to be dating someone
me too I just need I want him to have a
happy and I just wanted to be AJ in my
loan or Rita Ora
even though Rita Ora is truly to blame
for the downfall of Rob Kardashian even
though it's not nice to blame someone
for like I don't I don't think so
but he really like she cheated on him
with jay-z allegedly but she did cheat
on him and like he just never recovered
it's like he his self-worth was just
like in question and and then it led to
the depression and then he did it like a
lot of drugs and it just like it all
started from that moment I'm not saying
like it was necessarily that what
happened but was that time in his life
that was the last peak of Rob Kardashian
and then he got a tattoo of her that
looks like a Cabbage Patch Kid that's a
cute the Adrienne Bailon
episodes are some of the greatest my
more they lived together and he was such
a neat freak and he like you should
drive her crazy he was like in college
like in business like being coming a
business man like he him and Corey are
the only ones who graduated from college
that's so crazy it's so great it's so
crazy and okay I'm just gonna jump right
in because it's a natural progression
it's so crazy how
the dynamics of the sisters have changed
so much over the years and last night it
was truly a testament to that first of
all chloe sat next to Andy and Andy
in his defense he said Chloe's my
favorite because she's only one who's
come on the show and if I like by
herself before the LA thing last year
okay and Chloe was the one who got the
three of them to do it she texted them
she was like Andy's doing this thing and
I lied let's do that and they calls it
the and the interview they didn't even
know the name of the show that they were
on but they respect Andy and they knew
Andy they were like congrats on your
baby like they respected the whole
process I you know in Andy and his books
he said sometimes when they get a big
public star the stars publicist will
like give them two or three things like
not to say and he really respects that
they did not I firmly believe that they
didn't give them him one thing not to
say he spoke about everything every
question was so salacious and they did
not blink they handled it like true
professionals and that's a you know they
don't have like skeletons in the closet
but at the very end he asked him
something and you her eyes I thought she
was gonna cry Akiva at least save that
for me yeah yeah but it was just really
impressive how like they head on they
did a whole segment named the beef or
whatever squash the beef and Taylor she
was like I'm over it I'm sure she was
really like relaxed about it
Tristan she oh oh my god they have the
greatest video she goes and he goes to
Courtney Courtney and talked the whole
time literally I felt so bad for like
she might as well not have been there
they had a clip of and it was paparazzi
video of Eunice and Courtney walking
into a restaurant and they're walking
into a restaurant it's sitting outside
the restaurant as Lisa and Ken yes I
mean II and Courtney walks right by her
and Courtney was dying she goes I swear
I did go out and say hi to her
afterwards I didn't hear the first
Courtney but they didn't get that one oh
she knows her I guess Wow but it was
such a funny video it's Mary's like came
watches a lot of like random TV but she
doesn't watch Bravo she doesn't watch
Housewives she doesn't watch banter from
I know that's weird I hope like she
doesn't even need to get her into it she
does but I guess like she has kids so
what did you see John Legend's birthday
party picture of course I think it's
like so like funny how like a trend now
is that every birthday party even if
you're not famous like it has one photo
up when you when you get there so you
never like don't get a picture I'm into
it but you get it out of the way and
then everyone is talking about like that
one moment I think it's cool Kim looked
so good I just like didn't like her
alpha but she looks so skinny I mean she
is so straight like a sweatshirt around
her waist how did she look on the show
not no it's so weird they didn't really
promote this now I know our man's in
store I watched last week Danielle Staub
and Lindsay Lohan which you have to
watching watch Lindsay Lohan show okay
thea watched it and he said it's not
great yet but it has potential I heard
it has potential um so like they promote
they always are promoting and like when
they did like when Jayla was coming on
and they had like the countdown um 30
days then extravaganza when they Lady
Gaga the Oprah what was countdown to
Oprah and Mariah Carey yep they must
have just booked it that's why because I
did see a schedule floating around on
Twitter of the watch happens live shows
and it said TBD for a lot of people so I
think they were just like really booking
people last minute okay here's what a
reason why I want to start talking about
this isn't the dynamic of the sisters
have changed Khloe is like I want to say
she's a second the third most famous
like when they just they did a watch
happens live TV poll who has the best
style they give it to Khloe I know Liz
Kim dead Kim was dead but just like
given the way that they looked like
Kourtney looked so basic and weird
Kim's outfit was honestly it was
terrible like and I love her it was
terrible and her hair was terrible -
okay Chloe looked amazing so like fer
for the show and maybe people got
confused they were like who looks best
right now
got it okay Chloe looked amazing and
Chloe was really like the star of the
show was so interesting and they did a
game like who do you call when this
happens and Kourtney and Khloe I mean
Kim and Chloe set each other for
everything nobody said Kourtney not once
okay and can't Ben was watching me and
he was like dying at Kourtney's
awkwardness and at the very end the
Kourtney got the minutes to say
something like totally irrelevant and
she said it and you don't like you don't
know the sentence is over so it's like
dead quiet then screamed at the top of
his lungs it was so awkward like I
wonder if she definitely felt awkward
she was also in the third seat which was
hard yeah I hope that they were filming
behind in then we'll find out like why
they went out and we're so weird like it
was definitely a fight beforehand there
was giving me fight vibes
oh okay I have to watch I'm so excited
you saw that Kendall and Courtney were
in Aspen together and they got a flat
tire and Kim was like I actually know
how to fix a flat tire she commented on
the picture if you had invited me so
maybe there is some weird [ __ ] cool yeah
I'm into it
well Kourtney and Kendall from this
lessees and are like starting to like
create their own like thing yeah
annoying wieder well because Kourtney
dates people Kendall's age true I just I
can't like
and I just love Kim and I love Chloe and
I'm on their side forever so yeah like
if there's a fight and I love that their
closeness like it's interesting to watch
like the relationships change because
like remember when Kourtney and Khloe
were diehards like you snap you just
asked and they were like so me - show me
- Kim like with her Vogue cover and they
were so mean
but now Khloe and Kourtney like Khloe
and Kim are like ride-or-die and I love
it I love it as well I think Khloe's
like turning back into one my favorites
same okay I can't wait to watch no it's
so good I'm actually in watch after show
later I never watched you have to show
next step and if every sorry and it was
it was 100% live I thought it was
pre-taped because Andy was like there's
been a lot of rumors about you having a
baby even though it's like totally true
and I thought maybe this was like before
I just hadn't confirmed it well she also
confirmed that it's a boy excited and
they did a whole thing with names like
what would you name Chuck hago is a girl
girl I know I always get confused yeah
super cute because the name is like so
androgynous yeah that's right word yes
Chicago is also the cutest baby ever Kim
makes the cutest babies if I was her I'd
never stop me - okay Anna Faris
congratulate X Chris Pratt on his
engagement Anna Faris isn't keeping
quiet about her ex-husband Chris Pratt's
engagement to Katherine Schwarzenegger
quote I'm so happy for you both
congratulations
the actress commented on Pratt's
Instagram photo announcing the
engagement and then she also mentioned
it on her podcasts oh is what I saw in
the in the morning toasters that she
like came right out the gate like on her
new episode like congratulations to them
and she was excited but so when I was
sort of thinking about a yesterday we
were like the timeline like it's so fast
but you know when celebrities announce
their divorce or breakup it's already
been like six months in here like they
just haven't told us so now that I think
about the timeline isn't that weird Anna
Faris is dating someone else and she was
seen with this person two months after
they officially announced that they were
getting divorced so I actually do feel
like they are really happy for each
other but I just don't know I can't
imagine being that happy for someone
like falling in love with someone else
but like I was once in love with that
person and maybe I'm just not that
mature but like even if God forbid 1
million times me and dad got divorced
and we were so happy in our lives I'm so
pissed like you know I guess that I'm
allowed to be with anyone like if me men
ever got divorce he might as well die
because I'm never going to let anyone
anyone get into bed with Ben even if I
don't even love him anymore which would
never happen
you know would you let CEO got into bed
with no he was mine totally totally
I got spam we need to put up cut draw
draw up some papers
um it's see ya it's not super suit I
don't know it's something about this is
just like so shocking to me I know she's
in her 20s like Anna Faris is in her 40s
like even though she's so eligible and
unsuitable I don't know it's still like
a little bit scandalous but their their
relationship is so rooted in the faith
it's still fewer yeah but I don't know
no and I looked at her Instagram because
you said that you follow her and like it
wasn't that premium no she's cute
she's cute but like her Instagram I
didn't follow okay like I didn't like I
wasn't converted okay
well I only I follow her she follows me
okay that's fair fair enough
oh my god also do you know who I found
out follows me on Instagram there used
to be this like the egg yes but there
used to be this program that like could
find like you're famous followers or
like you're influential followers but
since Instagram changed their whole
thing I can't use it anymore so I just
have to like rely on people telling me
Cara Delevingne she's now my most
followed follower she's 40 million
before that I was Harry he is 20 million
Cara and being like a good fault I don't
want her to unfollow me I'm being a good
follower like I'm lucky I'm commenting
did you see that thing with her in our
Kelly not hand our Kelly but she like
did a whole Instagram post about like
how he's so disgusting and she lost like
a hundred thousand followers well I did
I thought she did a follow-up post and
she's just like she's not stopping like
she's going in good to hear it okay next
up some breaking news this morning
Alicia Keys to host the Grammy Awards oh
okay
the singer made the announcement on her
social media channels with a
behind-the-scenes video the Grammys have
found their host Alicia Keys will be
hosting the 2019 Awards it's official 15
time Grammy winner at Alicia co-hosts
the 61st Grammys marking her first time
as a master of ceremonies for music's
biggest night announced the official
Grammys Twitter account here for it
before it like throughout time she's
getting the respect she deserves
I mean she is that was on the voice so
she can hold her own hmm I think this
will be great she'll have like awesome
wardrobe change she has 15 Grammys yes I
wonder if she's gonna wear makeup she's
she doesn't like she doesn't tank up on
the boys right yeah she probably won't
go like honestly the biggest platform
that would be so epic like I would love
that because we buy hosts at the Grammys
I don't want our makeup but I would yeah
that is break season that's brave season
I'm
cited me too I didn't know he had 15
Grammys that's a lot cheese a real last
name keys it feels like it's almost too
good to be true because she's such a
good piano player it's it's definitely a
seat Wikipedia yeah I love things
definitely like Johnson yushik he's real
name
there's no way dude Alicia Augello cook
yeah okay I just wanna cook isn't Alicia
cook is cute too if she were a chef but
heard like being this amazing piano
player when are the Grammys Oh February
10th
oh because that's the day I'm doing a
show I got stuff to talk to you about
work stuff I just remembered cool
she'd be logging off February 10th I'll
be in Huntington New York Long Island
New York for so sold out second jobs
still available okay and the contest
just performed at that venue and I start
Kacey Musgraves there a couple years ago
so it's like really it's it's a big
moment for me
we're breezing through the stories
because we have so much like other [ __ ]
to talk and also we've still been on the
air for 30 minutes like our fourth story
is not for it's not really news but it's
more about commemoration ten years after
the Miracle on the Hudson yes today's
the ten year anniversary of cap tea
captain Chesley Sully Sullenberger 'he's
miraculous landing on the Hudson well I
was watching The Bachelor last night and
they were putting on a commercial for
Good Morning America like a whole tent
like a anniversary special for Sully and
I'm like why do you talk about this now
but now I realize it's cuz it's the
anniversary and I was thinking about it
like I haven't thought about Sully in a
long time like probably this is the
longest stretch I've gone you haven't
thought about him since
tbg since CDG wards where i haven't
thought about the man the movie or the
dogs and there was like oh why and it's
because I met him and I was so
disappointing because I told you what
happened to me what because I met him I
got my picture taken with him oh yeah
and it was like a professional photo and
Claudia like took him on my phone but
they were blurry and we looked like two
figures but I tracks knees I just
figured I was getting some extra [ __ ]
because we had a full photographer right
and we looks like two figures out of
Madame Tussauds Wax Museum who was
moving day I'm like Sully and Jacqueline
- my picture with Sully
cuz like sorry so then I was like
waiting for my picture from the
professional photographer to post for
you guys and so many people asked like
where's the Sully picture and his team
didn't
ever approved any of the photos of me
and him like Claudius got through so
many people's that through mine didn't
and I don't have like a real picture
with Sully so I'm like they say don't
meet your heroes and now I know why so I
think they're not gonna approve your
photos my pictures honestly I what did
you wear the TPG Awards SATs Vil yeah I
think it was just that you looked
thoughti
but like so Celie could have thought e
fans give it like it's just not really
on brand for him as an American Hero you
know why America is filled with thoughts
hold on so my picture with Soleil is
with me and then I've never looked
happier in my entire life Jake on the
email to you okay
I want to pull up my wax museum picture
then okay
so just what's so interesting about this
photo interesting factoid that's
interesting exactly is that I don't
think I've ever looked skinnier in my
life and in a photo and it's like slowly
just bring that out in me you know
and for that I'm eternally grateful I
said didn't do the impossible I just
think everyone should see it it's me Ben
and Sully Ben looks like such a nerd
like we were both like really like I
never met like a hero before right oh my
god that's a terrible photo I'm sorry
that's my fault
no but it's I'm just so upset like I'm
so upset really guys don't meet your
heroes I understand
wait um emailing this team they look
like such a nerd like we're both so
happy and that's because I've never met
like a hero like he's famous for being
heroic like I've never met Chris Kyle
you know who's another like famous hero
who they're they're similar Stein Emily
ever not her yet people who are like not
who are famous for their we're like for
their actions not for like a totally
Earhart right I mean she's not a hero
because she failed no offense
stop what if you would Amelia Earhart
lately justice for her where is she
where the [ __ ] is she I don't know I
need to do a little bit more research on
it but anyways today is the 10-year
anniversary of the Miracle on the Hudson
which is so crazy that it was ten years
ago ten years of Sully being you know in
the public eye and it's just incredible
it's just so weird cuz like I was alive
ten years ago I know I mean we're in
high school so like I guess we went high
school on the east side so we wouldn't
have seen it coming down the river on
the west side no but actually I went to
a while ago I went to a cher Monson's
office and it's on the west side it's in
this like really tall building and you
see the whole Hudson and she's worked
there for a while and she said they
thought I was in their concert maestro
that's him she said that was right there
I saw it like it's rather insane I
imagine if he saw a
tumbling down like that's just a weird
thing about like living in New York it's
like you were here for so much [ __ ] like
9/11 Sully think you could look out your
window and just see something crazy at
anytime someone just made don't look at
the comments I want to read it to you
someone just made the hilarious analogy
that analogy thought because you didn't
get to meet silly because you were a
thought that ho over there Sully is that
hero over there but like how are they
how are hos supposed to turn into heroes
if we don't get to meet our people like
Sully I mean don't you wear again oh
yeah come on I mean but here's the thing
guess it was a thottie dress but I'm not
a thottie looking girl
no your hair like you could really never
be thottie and like your your porcelain
skin
any thoughts don't have porcelain skin
they have bumpy skin the dress is so
small but I'm so small it went to my
knees it's really really anyways
so even though it's the 10-year
anniversary of the miracle it just
reminded me so everyone saw the picture
yeah I did look so skinny like usually
when I wear a tight dress I have like
that little belly like right in front
but like maybe slowly like cropped it
out because it's not there it's like the
best photo of me ever I mean they call
him the miracle worker first not for me
that's so true making jegi making danger
and stomachs disappear since 2009 here's
mine on the stream haha two wax figures
from the museum who gots put next to
each other on cleaning day I know you
really do look like a wax figure it's
super impressive how like you're holding
your pose like so poised right there's
nothing fat even though there's honesty
there's nothing fatty about that pose
good for you well at least we have that
right at least we have that anyways I
just I will never get it maybe we should
watch a movie today just to
commemorative so much to do today like
I've only seen that movie once and like
- it really just stuck with me like I
never need to see it again it was like a
fine film that I definitely don't need
to see again yeah
by the way been watched so many movies
on Zak's bachelor party that like I
guess he's never seen right and he's
like making me want to like he's like we
have to watch you've ever seen the Love
Guru what's it called
they love ya with awesome power Mike
Myers yes oh my god I said we have to
see it it's so funny Mariska Hargitay
and I'm like what that movie is like
reason why he doesn't work and no he
said it was like the best movie and then
we're stronger today was in it
like he doesn't such a rat race like he
ate all the honeymoon I've never seen
that he said we have to watch and I'm
like I have so much TV to watch between
three hours in The Bachelor like please
potato festival documentaries that are
coming out which you only need to see
the one on Julio totally ok did the
final story and something that if you
watch a show yesterday this isn't really
news to you but Selena Gomez breaks
social media silence after an egg takes
over for the most like Instagram photo
and so she was you know giving it her
best shot and after the morning she was
projected at literally two hours before
after taking a nearly four month hiatus
from social media Selena Gomez has
returned to Instagram with a message for
her fans quote it's been a while since
you have heard for me but I wanted to
wish everyone a Happy New Year and to
thank you for your love and support
last year was definitely a year of
self-reflection challenges and growth
it's always those challenges which show
you who you are and what you are capable
of overcoming trust me it's not easy but
I am proud of the person I am becoming
and look forward to the year ahead love
you all
so yesterday in case you missed the show
we said now that the egg has surpassed
Soph like Kylie's was 18 million the egg
last time I checked was that like 30
million like in order to get some a real
person to this benchmark it would have
to be like the craziest thing ever like
Selena Gomez being like oh I did crack
and she didn't actually say that this
time which is disappointing but I would
really like this photo 7.1 million oh
okay that's a lot that's a lot I mean
it's no thirty it's no egg and like
everyone making other accounts like
famous chicken like oh my god please
stop it's so not funny and not yeah I
can't so much agony famous piece of
toast like okay fine fine then I'll
allow it
like you guys come on like stop being
such losers like get back to work think
of something original it's up to 41
million the egg
good I hope I hope it I hope no one ever
beats the egg did how many users on
Instagram are there 100 million right I
think way more they reach that benchmark
no 100 million is how many followers Kim
has oh yeah it must be like maybe like
500 million Wow I don't what the most
what weird cymose we could go like how
high can we go yeah I I can't wait to
find out and no one's ever gonna meet
the egg at this point no and I think
that's like what they wanted like this
is no longer a competition like yeah I
guess you can have like ever like here
you give you like the most like photo
this year no but forever
an egg is gonna be the most like picture
around instagramming you know I'm here
for it because what came first the
chicken or the egg
what do you what do you believe I'm team
chicken I'm team chicken - chicken -
team chicken because if there was an egg
a chicken I'd July yet right but but
then a chicken had to be born at from an
egg but God also just made the God made
Adam and Eve maybe made the chicken yeah
he just like put animals on the earth so
what does that drop - chicken the
chicken came first person depends what
you believe right because it's if God if
you dropped dropped an egg and crack
that's true yeah if you don't believe
like in the story in the Bible in
creation yes when you're more of you
know the clearest no but Big Bang the
Big Bang Theory is not mutually
exclusive from the story of creation it
is there's total separate big thing
you couldn't believe him both know you
can't the Big Bang is like there was no
God there was just the world bang it was
there no yes it is it's what I called
the beginning the world bang and Earth's
created from the Big Bang okay so no
Hanukkah bang I wish you watch friends
whatever this is way be above our pay
tree all I know about the Big Bang is
that I'm glad it's canceled
and all I know about totally and all I
know about creation and you know
whatever you believe is what you believe
11 of and make a wish Network show
Network show never show numbers no Joey
this is our Kelly girls justice where
they are Kelly that's what I'm saying
right is where is Arielle where is
Austria where is Ansari all whereas I
forgot where's Joyce Chilean where
choice to and rajulun no choice chillin
joy Jolin know her dad is John Jolin
she's very confusing yeah it was also
I'm I have a to meet greet I had three
this week and I got a bunch of feedback
about our network show and a lot of
people don't want us to have it they
think that it's gonna filter us and that
it's gonna be hard for them to watch and
like a lot of them cut their cords so
you know what I kind of agree I kind of
agree Tim and I don't think it we're
actually getting one so I get to dream I
can definitely let go of no I know it's
definitely like if someone came in offer
to some Network show like we would take
it but I just I don't think that's where
I mean we need to be legen ordered
because honestly like the only network I
really ever want to interested in being
on is Bravo and they don't really censor
that much like and II like the class
it's like the only thing they censor is
they put a belief button on so I don't
think they would censor us too much but
honestly I don't know if I can handle a
platform
big like I'm ready I would say [ __ ] like
that gets me in trouble and I could
finds its way back to Meghan McCain's
husband that I called him hot you know
right um like I think if I was on a TV
show like I couldn't be tamed and I
would I would I would like I would be
what brought us down do you know what I
mean right like he would be like megyn
kelly i would be the megyn kelly Qi or
NBC or whatever it is I understand no I
totally agree and I'm I'm happy here
me too I'm very happy um okay much to
discuss up on the docket bachelor
bachelor let's go first with bachelor so
virgin heavy last night like I was
really like getting sewn right I need to
know if it's gonna stop I really feel
like it's not it's gonna have to stop
because eventually they do move past
jokes and the show becomes very serious
once they get rid of all the villains
saying stupid stuff so very very heavy
but first second episode actually that
was pretty good me too I enjoyed it I
actually watch it looks really stupid I
was way more like at paying more
attention that I ever have in the past
maybe three or four years yeah and I
really think the girls just are super
they're also pretty they're so pretty
they're cute and interesting and
Colton's really holding his own like as
a bachelor like in every conversation
has with the girls each one feels a
little different and they all feel
special which is like dangerous but it
shows that he's like a nice guy and I do
see like a few real connections blossom
me too I mean obvious obviously he's in
love with Hannah G and so am i and it's
gonna take him I don't know if she's
wins and I don't think she does but it's
gonna he's gonna be in love with her for
like a few more weeks before anyone else
really is gonna be able to comment get
such and we haven't really seen like a
instant love like this I believe since
crystals like was smitten with Britt
yeah and she had to like really go crazy
in order for him to finally like - you
got over it and I don't think honey G is
crazy so they had a conversation last
night that was very similar to the
conversation between Lauren B and Ari
where Lauren B it was like week one and
she's like I'm having a hard time like I
love you and you're dating other people
my catarrh train and they had that
conversation last night where she was
like you know I'm starting to know the
feelings and like it's a lot and he was
just like I know because I've been there
and that's how you know it's real like
when Shawn booth had that - he looked
couldn't [ __ ] handle but she's having
it week one so but Lauren B had a week
one - and I was like [ __ ] I don't even
know you but then she ended up winning
right but I understand my han is
happening right now cuz in her mind
they're in a relationship and also like
Colton only has eyes for her he's giving
back Gigi
made her little speech about being
invisible and I he literally like might
as well have said I love you no tokens I
saw it in his eyes by the way he is so
cute but the Billy Eichner of it all was
too much for me like I was dying when
when he said maybe we have the first gay
bachelor right because there are a lot
of rumors that Colton's gay and I've
been looking like to his mannerisms like
sometimes they gave away the clues I
don't think he's gay I don't get any
sort of gay vibe from him at all but
like I felt like Billy Eichner mind if I
picked up on something because he was
like we're like and they're like reads
blinds and did you read the comments
section on his Instagram I'm Billy's
Instagram with Andy no and he was like
he told me I was his first like all the
gays are descending on call to like
maybe they're picking up on something I
don't know but they also love him like a
like cuz he is so hot I was watching
daily popping like Justin loves him I
was talking to Joey we didn't talk about
it I want to see Justin this weekend in
Mexico and I need to talk to okay and if
you've just got a message what's the
footage Matt I love the show
congratulations
keep going and just it's already because
I've been on this trip last year and he
was talking about this show and it was
like brand-new and it wasn't like what
it is now and he was just like talking
about in it was just so funny and honest
and like so impressed and proud of like
how far it's come in a year and I mean
it's not impressing because it is on Ian
like I'll push anything that they want
but what's impressive is that it's
actually so good and I really enjoy yeah
and honestly that's just in a more eon
it is but what's other I'll Chris huh
I don't really watch I don't know um she
it's necessary for her to be there to be
like to keep them on track and she makes
Justin Morgan even funnier by like
taking it a little bit seriously because
when it's just like three people sitting
around cracking jokes like it's the
jokes mean less when you're expecting
that I agree but the fact we like the
two of them are just so shady and funny
I think the funniest one it's like and
they were watching the morning show
right they really they do such a good
job I can't say enough good things about
daily pop so just please something he
has a big fan and sister I promise um
back to Colton so the group date at camp
was actually so cute but like that gave
me the this I was wondering remember
when they had the volleyball date on
next um next episode and then the losing
team ended up getting to say cuz like
they didn't show it but Vanessa Grimaldi
like they're a big tantrum um I was
wondering if he was actually gonna let
that team go home cuz it's like kind of
unfair like you get no time with call -
just cuz you suck at tug ofwar like that
doesn't mean you're not qualified to
date him no
I think that's fair one because it makes
it easier for us when there's less girls
on the group date like yes we people
really do that time and to like that day
date is really long if you found not one
way to catch his eye during the long day
light's not gonna happen no not that
it's not gonna happen but you need to
try a little harder like you did have
time not only do you lose but you didn't
make the most of the time that you did
have yeah so I thought it was fair at
all so I think that they made the team
strategically because the girls on the
yellow team I went home I didn't even
know them right and I don't need it
wasn't anyone special that I think he
would have missed out on time with right
but the girl who's never been kissed who
I'm loving Heather totally been like
doesn't believe that she's never been
good I saw his story I was dying it's
like even when you're like when you're
like a horny likes middle schooler you
know kiss anyone like I don't know look
on the cheek I don't know either
and I believe her I don't think she
would lie but at one I think it's cute
that there is like another version they
had to I'm sparse that there aren't more
and I was gonna be really not if they
kissed right then and there because for
your first kiss it's gonna be like right
after he kissed someone else and right
before he's kissing someone else and
that's how you know he's respectful
because he didn't do it yeah he they
need to go on a one-on-one yeah I see
longevity for the two of them I don't
think she's like the one but I really
liked her I first like the first episode
I thought she was kind of weird because
you know yeah she was being very josie
grossy never been here yeah but I
started Nev signed her and mine like
these girls are all still really young
like maybe they're right and the whole
age thing is really interesting because
I feel like on Nick season Nick was a
lot older and he had a lot of younger
girls and they were like so mean to the
younger girls like even Becca Martinez
they were like she's too young like and
the age thing is always like annoying
and they're always mean to the younger
girls but now the younger girls are like
mean to the older girls because Colton's
24 like is he gonna marry a 31 year old
I don't think so so I'm loving like that
the roles have reversed I hate hate hate
when people take like a moral
high-ground over someone because they're
like one year older like everyone has
that friend that's like Laurie six
months older them and that stalks them
like they're a [ __ ] child
it's so annoying and that's when the
thing on the batch like the way that
people spoke to Corrine even like
because she was 24 like who [ __ ]
cares it's not her fault that she got
cast on show where Nick was 35 also
what's so interesting is now the girls
at the core group of girls on the show
are younger than me which is weird and
then I was singing when they I can
always felt like they were older than me
but then I
Corinne and Raven was right which and
they were dating Nick which is so weird
so now I'm the age of like the core
group of girls really growing up
yeah it's paper in your great next it's
gonna be stitch and she'll be that's
gonna be the craziest season when the
snitch girls are on um and and snitches
they're having them on is she on the
show it depends who the guy is because
and I stand by this like I still love
Colton I love him so much
me too like I think he's doing a good
job I think he's doing a great job and
he's so cute he's so cute he's so hot
like that body he's just like a perfect
square you know I mean his shoulders are
so broad Billy Eichner was so funny like
I just I love Billy Eichner and I feel
like people who are so funny like Billy
Eichner like they never get where they
need to be like in in though in
Hollywood like they're how they would
just love to give people who are like
not talented more roles the Billy
Eichner is so funny and he gets so many
roles like good for him and his agents
yeah you know I mean obviously the camp
bachelor thing was a little triggering
for me as a camper myself and that they
didn't call him counselor snitch no I
mean that was just like a missed
opportunity in my eyes right and she
really would have helped those girls and
she would have snagged Colton in the
chorus I was so beautiful can we talk
about the demi Tracy Tabaka
okay first of all Tracy the wardrobe
stylist who needed to be arrested last
week who needed to be arrested last week
and this week like then someone wrote we
need to lock her up and throw away the
key every look is worse than the next
right and it wouldn't be so jarring if
she didn't brand herself as this
wardrobe stylist police confession
police right no it wouldn't be so
driving at when she was in a wardrobe
stylist but I wouldn't have noticed it
if she didn't come in as the fashion
please right who needed to sell the rest
so I mean honestly like it was obvious
that The Bachelor producers were setting
Demi up to be like the new Olivia Creedy
like have her be like crazy whatever but
now I'm such a seasoned viewer I see
right past that and it's obvious they're
just telling her when to interrupt their
telling her to put the robe on and I
don't think she was doing anything too
crazy and she kept making really [ __ ]
valid points just being like I'm here to
win win over Colton like I'm gonna spend
as much time with him as I can and when
she picked up the rose as a [ __ ] joke
for two seconds she was like it's mine
and when she picked it up I was like is
she gonna go bring it to Colton see and
I thought oh she's crazy but no she put
it down it was in joke